Narrator:
THESE PLATES ARE FOR SWITCHES
THAT WILL BE INSTALLED
IN HOTEL ROOMS,
AND THEY WILL INCLUDE SOCKETS
FOR THREE-PIN BRITISH PLUGS.
THE AUTOMATED TOOLING WRAPS
THE PUNCHED METAL AROUND A FORM
TO GIVE IT THE DESIRED SHAPE.
THIS FRAMEWORK WILL ALSO SERVE
AS AN ELECTRICAL
GROUNDING PLATE,
DISCHARGING ELECTRICAL ENERGY
FROM THE SOCKET
TO PREVENT SHOCKS.
A WORKER NOW ATTACHES
A MOLDED PLASTIC PART
TO A GROUNDING PLATE.
HE INSERTS A SCREW
IN A BRASS CONNECTOR
AND INSTALLS IT IN A SLOT
IN THE MOLDED PLASTIC.
HE INSTALLS A SERIES
OF BRASS TERMINALS.
AT THE NEXT STATION, A WORKER
ASSEMBLES FUSE HOLDERS,
CONTACTS, AND SPRINGS
TO THE PLASTIC STRUCTURE.
NEXT UP ARE LITTLE
SPRING-OPERATED
PLASTIC SHUTTERS.
THEY BLOCK THE SOCKETS WHEN
NOTHING IS PLUGGED INTO THEM.
MOVING DOWN THE ASSEMBLY LINE,
A WORKER INSERTS SPRINGS
INTO TWIN ROCKER SWITCHES.
SHE LOWERS A PRESS
TO SQUEEZE ALL THE SWITCH
COMPONENTS TOGETHER.
THEN TRANSFERS THE SWITCHES
TO THE ELECTRICAL UNIT.
ANOTHER TECHNICIAN SNAPS A COVER
ONTO IT.
HE PLUGS IT INTO A LIGHT BOX
TO TEST IT,
AND THE BULBS OF THE BOX
ILLUMINATE.
THIS CONFIRMS THAT THE SWITCHES
AND SOCKETS
ARE FULLY OPERATIONAL.
A WORKER NOW FITS THE STEEL
GRID PLATE TO IT
WITH THE SWITCHES AND SOCKETS
PROTRUDING THROUGH IT.
THIS PARTICULAR UNIT
IS ALSO EQUIPPED
WITH A ROUND EUROPEAN PLUG
AND A USB CHARGING PORT
FOR MOBILE DEVICES.
AT THE NEXT STATION, AN OPERATOR
SERVES UP BRASS FACEPLATES
TO A PRESS THAT BENDS
THE RIMS...
...FORMING A THIN LIP THAT WILL
FIT AROUND THE GRID PLATE.
A COMPUTERIZED WELDER
FUSES STUDS TO THE BACK
OF THE FACEPLATES,
PLACING ONE AT EACH CORNER.
THESE STUDS WILL FIX THE
FACEPLATE TO THE GRID PLATE
AND PROVIDE A SCREWLESS FINISH
ON THE FRONT.
WHEN IT COMES TO SWITCH
AND SOCKET COMBINATIONS,
THERE'S NO SHORTAGE OF OPTIONS.
AT THIS STATION, A WORKER
ASSEMBLES A PARTICULARLY LARGE
ONE WITH SWITCHES,
CHARGING PORTS, AND SOCKETS.
IT'S ALSO DESIGNED FOR
INSTALLATION IN A HOTEL ROOM.
HE SECURES THE CHARGING PORT
TO THE GRID PLATE
AND IT'S READY
FOR THE FACEPLATE.
HE ATTACHES IT USING
THE WELDED STUDS,
AND WITH THE FOLDED EDGING, IT
ENCASES THE GRID PLATE NEATLY.